[Music]
in phony healing news submitted by male
[ __ ] stamp that'll be pretty funny
do it yeah yeah you actually like a JK
news gemst and if I ever saw dude with a
[ __ ] stamp
I oughta get in control my laughter I'd
be laughing like crazy let me sit barbel
be great I would send them a lot more
clothes I don't keep laughing hey what
is it what is it Marquand I love you I'd
be really scared a South African pastor
is in hot water after pulling a fake
stunt is he is he going like in the
power of spirit yeah Jesus Christ amen
I used to like watching that Indian guy
Benny Benny her they do that when you
cook the food and they vote on your
plate Hana he's on the [ __ ] Christian
Channel the TV I know I don't know that
he comes up any [ __ ] smacks people in
the face they come back to life and [ __ ]
yeah yeah you are healed yeah I think
this is a similar similar [ __ ] Indian do
yeah it's an Indian guy what is this
name is Benny Hinn or some [ __ ] like
that why don't you pick up from your
seat it's [ __ ] funny dude you just
have a whole line of people you'll be
like Bam Bam Bam and they'll be like get
to my dog this is dirt bath he reminds
McDo Joe [ __ ] magic video [ __ ] yes
Holly no pastor Popoff Oh Peter papa
papa you see cells like your holy water
and he saw that youth holy book more and
then people are like I don't know where
it came from but I just got a check in
the mail for $10,000 yeah that's all
he's a straight-up so holy water I
remember those infomercials dude cuz I
wanted one I wanted that [ __ ] holy
water super bad I loved his name though
peter Popoff home it's a while now cast
member I robbed her de bout this but I
haven't seen it okay so let's watch it
my man though yes is it is it a joke yes
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
some holy powers real clear yeah Wow
mean something in inner Lane she's not
saying mother [ __ ]
oh my random one guy this way we go back
why is that guy looking like a [ __ ]
nutcrackers drumline and [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I know but jeez is he
like lost he was lost but every time you
said that word there's somebody in south
after saying what is wrong with you
why is he saying hamburger Oliva oh my
god you said me that clip I'm gonna keep
that thing I got a post that [ __ ] yeah
that's just amazing lot of Bosh that's
so crazy I can't believe you thought
you'd get away with that why can't
believe so many people believe well
how'd they find out it was fake was the
first question right because what if it
was real how they disprove it yeah well
I want to see him do that with someone
that was like severed in half
show me that doesn't work like that you
have to be back - did you see Ted no one
tagged out like ripped into little
pieces they can bring him back gonna sew
him up first
oh maybe if I would have saw the movie I
wouldn't have said that okay my video
doesn't know anything guys it's just one
all right I'm gonna stop I'm not gonna
talk anymore in this episode thank God
mad at booze oh he said god bless you
the guy in the video that was dead so
initially the church was saying like
yeah you know like he brought him back
to life and all that stuff but then they
backtracked obviously but he was they
were saying that the
and was dead before and then so what
this pastor did is that he just
continued the work of God to the point
to where now he just made him become a
life at once that's still very no I I
kind of it's really funny but it's also
really sad to me that people are this
[ __ ] dumb so willing to believe
something like that so the dead man
they is going to jail now yeah they're
reported that he was arrested pretty
important what about the past tours you
know past or is he gonna go to jail too
well they don't mention that but I mean
I should I hate cons man that's like the
worst [ __ ] taking advantage of people's
like vulnerabilities and then this guy
also helped with the difference that
where he pretended to use a wheelchair
and then that he like didn't cast new
people all the time it's the same one
YouTube channel if you come here come
here the same actors Bolivians of doing
the same like they cured the length of
her arms because well yeah I showed it
the eyes like he was dying no these are
really good like comedy ideas no they
are yeah literally I was putting a skit
together in my head as you guys are
talking like oh you actually do like a
fake pastor thing that'd be hilarious we
did one called stealing for healing I
have this idea for a pastor sketch but I
feel like it's if people might get mad
it was like a church of like it's called
the the Church of at work ship where
every time people catch the Holy Ghost
like instead of like date around they
starts working yeah and I wanna do might
be difficult to film that into Church
yeah I mean we could set something up to
look like a church if you get authentic
grandmas I'll be tight that could be
good and they start tortured true true
cuz I mean the Bible says you know like
I mean strippers new church too though
yeah true and it is just dancing I mean
if you want to think it's dirty that's
on your sinful mind you know I'm saying
it's just actually gives me boners it is
sinful if I ass is shaky like that yeah
that's emulating [ __ ] doggy style or
they're just dead
riding on your day or they're just
dancing as if anybody that tries to say
oh it's just a [ __ ] art form yeah it
is art form and it's communicating
erotica it's communicating lust because
you're a pervert miniature men are
trying for you yeah it's still it's
still a form of well I mean like
expression right but then it's
expressing sex it's not it's it's
OneNote right you can't express sadness
Deuter torquing it's not it's not a
dance of of sadness and grief right you
can't [ __ ] you know if she goes slow she
goes yeah I think I like that better
stripper and your thoughts on it things
do she is talented oh yeah she's good
why did she do that for so long she was
exhausted and I feel bad we did like
three or four takes sounds like after
every take I was like yo do you need
some water are you good you good we'll
do one more that's it that's it camels
have waters in their humps
that's her lady humps that need to
refill the biggest ass or as I would say
the fattest ass for an Asian girl really
I've seen some big booty Asian girls in
my day especially like for some reason I
like my prom date that I took the
problem she was she was Laos and she had
like crazy cakes especially for like an
Asian girl you know to the point where
like all Dyke because she was from a
different school so when I walked up
with her all the homies were like yo yo
never seen an Asian girl but that
happened to her ass it's still it's
still poppin what happened I like ass
yeah me too yeah I like it when girls
look like ducks
they just waddle right into the room
with your [ __ ] little quacking ass
yeah Asian girls can have booty mm-hmm
but that booty was excessive though it
looks like she could just if she died
like in the Donner Party she could have
kept that whole [ __ ] place of life
would just her ass you know you know
it's crazy um I find that um Cambodian
girls tend to have like booties like to
the point where when I was in Boston
because a lot of Cambodians in Boston I
was like oh well so probably is uh like
these these big Cambodian girls and like
I started calling Cambodians because
they oh they got booty is coming
Southeast Asian ladies yeah must be the
coconuts maybe be the coconut must be
the coconut must be the coconuts
[Music]